[Music]
ha and welcome to anyway I'm mr.
Burroughs I mean suppose a lot I had a
very hectic week week beast i am swedish
hello dick this king [ __ ] that was the
best joke I made this week anyway I
bought it so you bros can see it and but
that's pretty much the reason why i
haven't uploaded any videos as it was a
lot of rumors saying i was dead
maybe I am maybe I'm not we would never
know let's let's just start the vlog I
just wanna say I missed it was a lot and
so it that's a new thing by the way
changing things up by now how you doing
no not a good idea what do you know
about ideas I'm just gay
go
I got my parish me parachute did you do
it I'm sorry do it again all right I'll
do it
hey I got you okay
all right it's cold meat you know
everyday Maya why are you cheating whoa
that eyes oh who is this oh I'm sorry am
i interrupting
but it why would you not kiss me yeah
and we're gonna wake up ken is here he's
gonna look good nice t-shirt by the way
represent exactly that's what I thought
in my mind I was gay all right it's
gonna look good already don't come too
close okay again he's gonna look good
it's gonna look good he's touching me
he's touch oh there you got it thank you
you'll get it later hopefully actually I
hope they don't get it because then it's
gonna end up in a video and it's Ken
hey there's nothing awkward about a man
poke oh look out this is how it looks
like
it's pretty cool a lot of cameras a lot
of stuff and here's there's ladders do
it again it's so funny can't don't do
that don't do that until you're at least
13 oh it looks like we're gonna we're
gonna record with cry sorry what'd you
say something no I haven't yes I guess
we recorded cry I don't know how we're
gonna have a substitute for him oh wait
it's actually crying did we record with
Jesse just Cox and dot do ger and it's
been fun it's been fun uh we're gonna
keep doing it ken give me your best
4head yeah hi I'm here at the set for
good job Ken oh my god it's crying oh my
god I'm such a big fan that's typical
crying that's my thing everybody's not
like it's 9:30
I have not eaten I'm here with this
little pug just sick
she been at the vet for a couple hours
now and they gave her pain pill pain
kills no I'm saying I was tearing up a
little bit I don't know I'm worried
about her
but I think she'll be okay for now yeah
I'm [ __ ] starving so I'm gonna go
[Music]
this morning
ate its eighth and last day of recording
today we're gonna do a lot of big
collabs today I think your boys are
gonna love tonight I had for a while and
I'm glad a time only I don't know I'm
also sad leaving but I feel like God
most of the stuff that I wanted to do
done and I feel like I wanted to go to
LA to try out the the YouTube life and
yeah I got what I wanted lucky cool
things and collabs and all that kind of
stuff so I feel I feel really happy
about it
and yet it's alright haven't been
uploading videos my I was sick yesterday
like I mentioned she feels a little
better she still looks like well yeah
I'll see I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
are you trying to kill me
wait we're not driving we're just hi
brother hope you enjoyed watching I just
spent five hours sinking her footage
because he kept unsticking itself
thanks thanks Canberra I hope you
enjoyed watching the blog if you want
more vlogs go ahead and leave a like I
don't know me I don't know I guess
that's how it works and leave me a
comment telling me how much you missed
me because I missed you so much
in all seriousness even though I had a
lot of fun this week he brought our
oldest tire with me my heart and I I
miss making videos so much Thursday and
I miss you Ross it's good to be back I
will be lucky
- putting on birthday anyway it's good
to be back get to see your faces
can't really see them but that doesn't
matter I love this picture a beautiful
woman man whatever you have a problem
with me picturing people I think so
I always pictured forgets but anyway
stay awesome bros thank you for being so
crazy about me going away it makes me
feel special
hey say awesome love you so yeah
Libra waiting what do you think and now
this is a great selfie per second